welcome to this video playing before
Biff from the UK 1647 that's really no
rating to get in the five-minute blonde
ok so is playing h3 that's a very very
slow way to play ok many ways to to
counter such a slow move but ultimately
why it is still very solid it's not
possible to get anything anything
fantastic here with blackened I'm trying
to do is try to block deform and
ultimately try to to use the F porn c3
surprised me a bit maybe he wants to
play a plus play d4 at the end just not
something that I am particularly dislike
because of my bishops ok so yeah maybe I
can activate the Queen about him it's
not like not threatening Bishop 83 m but
it might still irritate them and I don't
see a direct drawback to the move maybe
rookie 82 to attack you for later
now might it might help to to scam with
the Queen on h5 I wonder membership to
g7 and then look at the age maybe
hmm yeah maybe maybe here first
yeah trying to centralize pieces I was
just about to say the good thing about
this position is you can always go into
to a good end game with the bishop pal I
can play night a five year maybe
maybe but I can take em at least this
gives them a double pond and slightly
divide the values whites structure so I
don't think night at five is really
great okay I wonder how to play here
maybe night to have form or is this
unreliable I may know maybe maybe go
here what I want is I want to exchange
before the d4 night maybe I can play
something like g6 96 okay well g6
weakens the dark squares districts g6 to
protect against Knight f5 but okay maybe
this wasn't a super great idea
hmm
now just improve a bit yeah 96 is always
maybe I can play f6 g6 and some some
improving lives and then go for the
night exchange I can place if I if I
mean maybe I should just play c5 and
push this away yeah that's actually true
why not just see 5 okay but I made good
preparation museum it's not nothing bad
happened okay he's just going for
voluntarily in a way okay check let's
take this
and once maybe once Bishop g3 but I have
to check here okay so just play a normal
move okay mmm it should be six now it
can can be brought into the game ship to
be three as good yeah I can do that
John Bishop g5 next yeah I'm starting to
to get some control him and yeah I've
got three against two on the queenside
and the support by the bishops
hmm 92 where c5
I can still play b6
yeah he's getting low on time
hmm should be a true
and I can play Rukia one come to a check
oh it doesn't okay I'm taking the
exchange maybe just here looking see 5
or covering c5 to see form and now I can
actually play this now that the night is
not coming anywhere
now first this huh and then we'll get
one no need to give a pawn
undergo a five hmm white resides yeah
this was a typical situation well white
um was okay besides the bishops and
besides except like having the bishops
and again I probably played it a bit a
bit slow here okay after my idea was to
go see five anyways so I wasn't
particularly concerned about this trade
I'm pretty surprised that I am Bishop g3
maybe still I was thinking the chocolate
I still don't understand if here my
stock fish a gives this as equal y y su
dewyze is equal I have two bishops for
nothing like it's just better in this
position yeah I don't understand some
computer valuations that's it's very
weird blank is really substantially
better yeah I don't know but in the game
I slowly came to invade the position and
it didn't help that he had no time on
the clock of course he can play here
this is this is better then I just
retreat and then go here and was just to
improve the peace position a bit yeah
okay pretty clear win thanks for
watching